do you have intrusive thoughts ever
while having an intense make out you
mean sex yeah it was like the last time
I had an intense make out I know it's
probably a long time
ago me
too so much so that apparently I've gone
back to the Prairie Land and I'm like
when you last had a kiss did you have a
thought that distracted your
mind yeah what like what I've run out of
in the in the kitchen when I have to
wake the kids up how we're going to get
through the day the logistics of who's
picking up who all the time but he's
well aware so it's
fine he's like hi are you in there oh my
oh yeah hi hi hi you are the coolest you
know how liberating that is for like
most women on the planet